[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
samedi matin la place d'une petite ville
comme les autres au sud de la loire
pourtant l'accent témoigne il ya là le
pharmacien de la grand'rue et l'épicier
du coin
le chef comptable l entrepreneur de
maçonnerie à moins que ce ne soit le
plombier le percepteur peut-être le
toubib la sphère visiblement est
d'importance encore qu'il ne s'agissait
ni d'élections on ne crée pas ni de
politique internationale
on est de trop bonne humeur mais on sent
bien pourtant qu'il se trame quelque
chose et que toute la ville en parle
7e marin ceux qui se rappellent même des
absences au journal
[Musique]
et bien sûr que tous les cas il faut
évoluer autrement
à bordeaux de même à des tiers oui à
quelles ont gardé au midi 11h en dehors
je ne serai à 11 heures ce qui vaut pour
les à bordeaux
non en dépit de la tranquille assurance
de l'épicier ce samedi là n'est pas du
tout un samedi comme les autres et la
petite ville n'est semblable à aucune
autre petite ville de france
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est que demain brive va à bordeaux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le portant de zone on semble déjà crié
la victoire tandis que les plus
réfléchis en sont à calculer un score
raisonnable les stratèges sont en place
j'ai joué 21 n'a jamais été mis à la
porte d'un terrain de rugby par un
arbitre parce que j'ai jamais donné
beaucoup au fait bravo jamais donné
aucune te dire que tu aies jamais donné
de coups qu'il l'ait vu plata du coup
l'arbitré travées vous me laissez pas
finir comme nationale du moment
c'était au début où alex talonner roanne
où il talonnait en équipe première
on est allé jouer à lourdes ah oui ce
fameux match
vauban et un talonneur alors il
s'appelait sans bastos était pas un
agneau 1 celui à seulement alex 7 et un
ratisseur et lui piquer la balle et ça
plaisait pas à ces menaces tous alors à
chaque mêlée il lui disait tu laisses à
cette valve petit coup je te chrtr comme
ça pour des gars c'est pas bien dans ce
prix avec celui répondu qu'une éducation
vous avez monsieur du jeudi saint nous
avons bien te dire que si quelques mails
et les coups de tête n'écrase pas un
nouveau prêtre là elle y serait passé au
dessus et le paquet avait ce jour là il
ya une discussion de pembe ligne au
stade comme jamais ils en ont vu dans
les processions dimanche matin c'est
parti
la grande opération est déclenché
[Musique]
non mais sérieux on est chez nous et à
tous tout à l'heure j'ai eu le souci de
monétisation sur la place à voir le
combat à l'aéro club vous écoutez ça va
nous sommes les meilleures années du
club athlétique prémices de gendt et je
vois qu'il pourrait passer pour moi je
parle
objectif bordeaux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
attention ce train là n'est pas celui
qui quotidiennement emmène les voyageurs
de bordeaux aujourd'hui c'est le brise
spéciale
[Applaudissements]
avec eur
mais valenciennes
[Applaudissements]
howe
non
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les refrains s'estompe c'est que l'heure
h approche
convergent sur la gironde sur terre et
dans les airs un bon 120 à l'heure de
moyenne le débarquement se prépare
[Musique]
chacun est à son poste
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
m
bordeaux saint-jean enfin et aussitôt la
place est investi en mono fétiche
antennes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
mais
on se retrouve au complet devant le
stade municipal et maintenant que le
choc est tout proche
une curieuse détente libère les uns et
les autres le temps de récupérer les
toutes dernières forces à la table du
restaurant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
car oui
cette fois on ne peut plus reculer on
fait bien encore semblant de plaisanter
mais en dépit des pancartes et des
chapeaux malgré la présence
réconfortante et rebondissante du numéro
on sent que l'heure est grave ils vont
sortir
[Applaudissements]
et c'est parti il y à quelque part là
bas un ballon et 30 hommes en colère
et dans 85 minutes pose comprise le sort
de bris sera joué
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à l'hybride mais maintenant on ne rit
plus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
au chrono les cinq dernières minutes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est fini ils ont gagné en bas dans
l'arène bien sûr mais également ici sur
les gradins qui menacent maintenant de
se rompre sous les regards des
supporteurs les supporteurs le
pharmacien de la grand'rue et l'épicerie
du coin
le chef comptable et entrepreneur de
maçonnerie le plombier ou le percepteur
peut être le toubib
regardez les bien ce soir demain à brive
vous ne le reconnaîtraient pas
[Musique]
vous pouvez même y passer
m
[Musique]